get what they get right and then as in
like men get what they get but then
women can choose I'm not sure like the
whole phrase yeah but I do feel like I
know we always speak about like how you
know we're all saying how like men it's
really hard for them and everything and
yes it is and nobody's disputing that
but I do feel like when it comes to
women I know and I don't know if anyone
would agree with me but this is how I
feel personally I do feel like the women
are more willing to improve themselves
and to do the work and to try and get
better and to become the best versions
of themselves
can you tell me how how do women improve
them so many ways different ways women
are literally trying to work on
themselves mentally like women women are
more open to therapy than men are
they're open to women getting help do
women need therapy more than men do
I think it's the other way around
actually because I feel like if a lot of
men actually went and worked on
themselves they would be able to get the
women that they wanted because a lot of
these men are walking around with
unresolved trauma a lot of issues
about them okay so okay so I just want
to go through so women go to therapy
yeah what else do we do they do all
kinds of stuff to Wellness
false wrong sixty percent of women here
so no 70 64 of women here overweight
false
you can't be into Wellness if most of us
are fat okay next
oh wow also
I'm talking about mentally they're
trying to fix them okay they're trying
to be mentally healthy women are there's
more women on antidepressants now than
ever wrong we're not mentally more
healthy well men are doing absolutely
nothing right nothing they're not doing
anything to help you do not think about
the societal issue okay okay
they get looked down upon for feeling
that way so they never want to go to
anyone no but that's a narrative that
they created for themselves because
they've told themselves that they have
to be really masculine but no woman has
ever sat there and laughed at her
husband for crying
I want to I want you to back up what
you're saying you're saying women women
they're into self-improvement so first
one was wrong second one's wrong what's
next Wellness is not wrong
how is it they are how is it right if
we're fat let's come on okay don't take
long to to get rid of it okay okay so
then we could look at a challenge
they're trying so so we could look at a
trend of women over time and we're
getting fatter We're Not Getting Thinner
so it's not correct you could think what
you think but it's not right well I
don't know we can look at what kind of
food people are eating but I'm the ones
that make us fat generally women if you
go on social media and you see what
everyone's talking about women are
always asking how do we do this how do
we do that they are trying to fix
themselves because they want to meet
that dream man that's why they run these
dating apps that's why they go to these
dating agencies I'm not getting anything
of substance
like nothing like okay they fix
themselves so they go to therapy they're
trying to help themselves mentally but
they're either they're on more
antidepressants than ever
so they might they might try to do
something but the result like we have to
look at results here we can feel how we
feel but we have to look at results
so if women are fatter than ever we're
more into on more antidepressants they
try to fix themselves like just they
they
but the difference is women can live in
delusion so women can go through life
and not like you know how many girls
come on here and genuinely tell me
they're tens do you know me girl you
don't you just don't have men do that
and they believe it I I have I I say I'm
an average chick on my show and girls
will look at me like oh and I'm like
most people are average I've never had a
girl come on here and say she slide
twice maybe twice the girls have come on
and said I'm an average girl every girl
thinks they're special I mean the top
ones are the ones men can say that about
themselves
no no men don't think they're special
because they should no because men men
have to face reality in the world if
they're if they ain't [__] they're gonna
know the world's gonna tell them where
women will they'll say oh you're so
beautiful anyway oh you're a ten of
women we lie to each other too you'll
never tell your friend that she's fat
women tend to lie to themselves though
yes I don't I wear don't get me wrong I
definitely lie to myself every day but
woman will perceives themselves as a
person that's wearing the makeup I've
done their hair done this men don't do
that so they look at themselves and they
they may feel [__] about themselves but
they're going that's who I am women will
look at themselves with makeup on and go
I'm a 10 the minute that makeup comes
off they feel so insecurable why we are
more like that proves that we are trying
to help ourselves we are trying to
improve ourselves we'll do anything
um
we'll do anything but the hard [__]
I agree like they won't like lose weight
and things like that why would I push
back on the on the notion that guys
aren't doing anything self-improvement
though because like I'm part of a you
know this whole Space you know these
these guys are I mean maybe it's not the
biggest place in the world but but but
yeah I would agree with that but maybe
you're in an echo chamber you know who
you're looking at on Instagram you're
looking a lot of girls maybe they're
into the self-improvement the wellness
stuff fine but I'm also I also know a
lot of guys who are also working hard I
mean what do guys have to work on you
know money muscles going frame basically
so you know are you leveling up
financially are you working on your
career are you on your mission are you
going to the gym uh you know are you
looking after your fashion or you look
after groups so guys do need to do a lot
and the truth is if you are a reasonably
attractive
girl in her say 20s okay we're not even
talking about a town we're talking about
like a girl who's a six or seven
whatever five
um you don't have to do very much to get
validation from the dating Market or you
don't have to do very much you have to
be kind of cute wear a summer dress walk
down the street and you're gonna get
guys you know who are who are sort of
like complimenting you or whatever
except that's illegal now but you know
back back when we used to be allowed to
talk to each other that would you know
you would get that positive validation
whereas dudes actually for the most part
are invisible to women unless
they've really worked on themselves
unless they've done the necessary thing
and I think if men aren't self-improving
it's women's fault because men have to
be motivated by something
so what do they what again what do they
get at the end of it they get that women
that think it's okay to leave
so what kind of wife are they getting at
the end of it yeah or you get that one
meal a day yeah see if you're lucky oh
you get this whole bunch of guys who
have sort of dropped out the sister
because they think the dating is
completely unfair because they think
they're invisible 20 80 of guys are
invisible to women so they think we'll
watch it in cells
they're they're dangerous
I didn't even know that word
um
I would say that
again it's the fault of women because
again if if there's in cells why is that
it's because women are all sleeping with
the same men I I think though
just based on psychological evidence
there's a lot going on there that's
deeper than just societal means but I
get what you're saying about like in
retrospect but in cells themselves but
then I also there's much deeper side I
don't agree with that because what you
just said I I would say but they all
want us to be virgins so yeah we are
sleeping with the same person or
whatever like yeah but why aren't we
virgins because we chose to have sex
outside of marriage and two guys do not
expect a virgin that is the most
[__] [__] I've ever heard in my life
no what do you expect do you expect a
virgin no I don't know I've never seen a
single guy that says he expects a virgin
I think that's an immature I think
that's the ideal but they don't I think
that's much younger yeah yeah it's it's
much younger I think men are realistic
younger actual age-wise the younger oh
yeah you guys who are stuff like that
yeah technically
I think the whole thing is quite nuanced
though because because to cancel what
I've just said you are right there's a
lot of guys who are very very lazy and
they don't want to do the work they
don't want to [__] do anything they
sit there and this is We complain about
this a lot you know they sit there on
the computer going oh it's really unfair
if I'm not a six foot if I'm not a seven
foot five Chad with you know blah blah
blah then I'm not then it's over for me
they don't do anything they just sit
there complaining and you know that that
is on them because also they need to be
going out and they need to be they need
to be working on themselves you know so
I think human beings human beings in
general are inherently lazy most most
people but if again if you are a
reasonably Q you know young woman I
think you get more breaks in society
than than a dude of the same level
yeah I hear that oh yeah
okay I'm gonna take a second to read
super chats guys make sure you like the
video that's the most important metric
that YouTube uses to push out these
streams okay
Geoff thank you for the Super Chat Tomo
a men Improvement channels be be top
five percent women Improvement channels
makeup news rules fashion Carlos all men
can remember the day we could no longer
get help from adults because we weren't
a small kid anymore men have to earn it
on their own Fernando um in this world
there's only one thing that matters hard
facts people misguidedly choose to
accept the truth they are comfortable
with them realizing things that may
things may not we have had expected them
to be unsettled unless it's overwhelming
Jordy if you're leaving for a better man
he will leave you for a better and
younger woman that's a fact
Tomo J Nora Vincent self-made man learn
her name uh Charles uh Stone compromise
is something that can be used to find a
solution where both parties win uh
the Adam Ant these women are average
looking at best the fact that they think
an act like this is a testament to how
screwed Society is today sorry Pearl
thank you for your content I see
Dumbledore wifey sorry girls um that's
not you Aaron uh women women select a
tall a man taller Stronger Faster older
wiser smarter and higher income they
want a level-headed confident leader to
protect defend and provide the Proclaim
that then Proclaim that we are equal
follow me question um what do you think
a husband is for keep him in mind
um how much you have thrown around the
word equality before you answer dark
Lane
um
uh fruit Freddy um what women fail to
understand is that they manage is is
what women fail to understand is that
they manage the home to a high value man
so it's managing day-to-day operations
of the home
he's out Gathering resources that you
can manage at home
um
blessing their magic and open up the
chat
D um I got my kitchen done recently and
two women did the measurements uh the
men built the kitchen but realized
before we were starting the measurements
were wrong
[Laughter]
um greatness there's no benefit to be a
man in a relationship with a woman with
with no plan of marriage you say
relationships are okay but they're an
excuse to marry um ladies would you
marry a man just like your father
um follow me Tyrese would have been
canceled if the rules were reversed
Nathan asked the panel what type of cat
they want in the future question for the
panel if being obese is being acceptable
as body positive should people that are
anorexic be accepted too it's their
choice uh that's actually a good
question Saint man um do good wives fart
and then laugh
um air Nathan Arbor um the lady who is
getting oh I read that one already I'm
gonna refresh it real quick guys
um also guys make sure you sign up for
our Google forum for our next event I
think we're going to do a meet up in
London um it's gonna be a lot of fun the
last one we did um you went to it right
yes yeah yes it was fun
um what was the question that I read up
here that I thought was decent what do
you guys think a husband is for
um I would say a provider
um
um I would say also Man of the House
um as I said before companion to be your
best friend
um also to honestly to push you to be
that better person that is so important
um and a good father I feel like a lot
of no offense a lot of
a lot of men haven't been taught what a
good father is because they didn't have
that experience and that's unfortunate
and that's just being passed down to the
Next Generation to the Next Generation
to the Next Generation and that's
that's something I think is really
important someone that is a good father
has good morals okay uh what do you
think
um
I think he's a
protector definitely someone who is
I don't want to say like Shield me from
the world but someone who is gonna have
my back
um
make sure that I'm safe at all times
um emotionally
like men today financially
um and someone that I can just do life
with like my life partner someone that
can be by my side and face these
challenges that we face in life together
okay what do you think what's a husband
for
I think
I don't know to be honest
I don't know you don't know no I think
it's an honest answer I don't know
honestly I I don't know but you are
you're from Romania though which is
quite yeah still quite um
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible